du hast gerade eine entscheidung
getroffen du hast dich dazu entschieden
auf dieses video hierzu klicken
warum hat sich das vorschaubild dieses
kleine thumbnails angesprochen war der
titel interessant oder kriegst du
vielleicht immer auf die videos von
diesem kanal hier so eine entscheidung
zu treffen klicken oder weiter scrollen
dauern zirka anderthalb sekunden
wir treffen sie jeden tag 100 vielleicht
sogar 1000 fahren und dennoch
beeinflusst diese kleine entscheidungen
ganze branchen netflix zum beispiel
untersucht für jeden film und jede serie
ganz genau welche forscher bilder
trailer und texte am besten ankommen am
ehesten zum klick führen und aus diesem
grund sieht ein und derselbe film auf
netflix bei mir vielleicht anders aus
als bei dir das ganze nennt sich a b
testing das sind kontrollierte
experimente die tausendfach und
dauerhaft überall im internet laufen auf
netflix instagram reddot und wenn du
dieses video hier gerade schaust du bist
auch du mitten in einem test und wie das
funktioniert das erkläre ich euch heute
dieses video wurde unterstützt von
wittmann ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht
aber ich habe auch das gefühl dass meine
bank noch nicht so wirklich im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert angekommen
ist wird man nie ist ein neues startup
dass das jetzt ändern will
hier wird alles über die app gesteuert
ist einfach gestaltet und minimalistisch
zum beispiel kann man sein geld in so
genannten pocket organisieren
das ist super praktisch wenn man für den
nächsten urlaub oder ein fahrrad geld
zur seite legen will
neben der app kriegt er noch eine
kostenlose metall karte mit der ihr vor
ort bezahlen könnte außerdem gibt es
cashback prämien das funktioniert zum
beispiel bei supermärkten und cafés aber
auch bei abos wie netflix disney plus
und amazon prime da bekommt man zum
beispiel zehn prozent seiner monatlichen
gebühr zurück insgesamt kann man jeden
monat bis zu 20 euro cashback erhalten
und dieses geld kann sogar noch vermehrt
werden indem er jetzt mit einer aktie
wie zb tesla verknüpft richtige aktien
kauft ihr dabei allerdings nicht ihr
könnt von steigenden kursen profitieren
und das geld wird mehr aber ihr werdet
niemals geld verlieren wenn die kurse
sinken
wenn wir das jetzt interessant findet
dann könnt ihr ein kostenloses konto bei
wittmann eröffnen den link dazu findet
ihr unten in der video beschreibung
übrigens wenn wir schon beim thema daten
sind wir können ja sehen wie viele von
euch die kanal abonniert haben und wie
viele nicht und relativ viele zuschauer
haben den kanal nicht abonniert gucken
aber trotzdem jedes einzelnen video
wenn ihr das seit und ihr wollt nicht
verpassen wenn wir neue videos hochladen
dann abonniert gerne den kanal damit
unterstützt sie uns auch noch mal das
heißt man kommt mehr daten ansammeln zu
einem genaueren muss oft unterlaufen
apps websites oder sogar filme ziemlich
kontroversen änderungen zum beispiel hat
netflix vor einiger zeit die sterne
bewertung mit einer individualisierten
prozent bewertung ausgetauscht woher
auch immer die idee kam oder das reddot
design gegen das sich die community
immer noch wert und auf facebook sieht
seit kurzem ganz anders aus solche
änderungen sind wie man immer wieder
sieht kontrovers und klar mit netflix
rettet oder facebook mit so einer
änderung keine nutzer verlieren werden
neue features designs und alle möglichen
anderen änderungen im vorfeld getestet
und zwar an uns um herauszufinden ob
eine änderung den nutzern gefällt oder
vielleicht sogar mehr kunden anlockt
machen unternehmen so genannte a b tests
das ist mittlerweile eine der
wichtigsten testmethoden im online
marketing bei a b tests werden zwei
zufällig ausgewählte gruppen mit
unterschiedlichen varianten desselben
produkts konfrontiert also version a
gegen version b das können version einer
app eines trailers oder einer website
oder vielleicht sogar nur eines vorbild
sein und genau deswegen kann es gut sein
dass derselbe film bei netflix bei dir
anders aussieht als bei mir so können
die mitarbeiter von netflix daten
sammeln und in echtzeit sehen wie neue
filme poster und ideen von nutzern
angenommen werden je nachdem ob ich zum
beispiel aus deutschland oder den usa
komme spricht nicht eventuell eine
bestimmte bildsprache er an dass der
film dahinter genau derselbe ist ist gar
nicht so wichtig wichtig ist wie gut
dieser film im marketing dargestellt
werden kann
deswegen gibt es typischerweise für jede
show bei netflix eine riesige anzahl an
cover art die alle aus getestet und
miteinander verglichen werden
dieses auswahlverfahren hat netflix
übrigens inzwischen automatisiert man
nennt das ganze dort ästhetik visual
analytics
dafür wird jedes einzelnen standbild
einer serie oder eines films analysiert
und bewertet
am ende soll so für verschiedene
zielgruppen das jeweils beste filmposter
herauskommen
das kann bei uns allen unterschiedlich
sein trotzdem gibt es wohl ein paar
dinge die immer gut funktionieren wie
zum beispiel die hauptdarsteller zu
zeigen
logisch dass rwe verfahren erkennt
nämlich die hauptdarsteller automatisch
an ihren gesichtern
was hingegen nicht so gut funktioniert
sind sensible themen wie gewalt werbung
oder nacktheit am ende kommt so eine
reihe von potenziellen cover bildern
heraus die jeweils verschiedene nutzer
ansprechen sollen und welche cover dann
für welche zuschauer wirklich die besten
sind das finde netflix durch a b tests
heraus meistens bekommen wir davon aber
gar nichts mit unterschiede änderungen
oder neuerungen sind oft so klein dass
wir sie nur unterbewusst wahrnehmen
und selbst wenn würde netflix uns nicht
wissen lassen dass wir gerade getestet
werden das könnte nämlich die ergebnisse
verzerren
trotzdem können wir mit sicherheit sagen
dass du schon mal ein testobjekt warst
denn du hast auf dieses video angeklickt
und sich damit für ein bestimmtes samuel
entschieden
[Musik]
wenn wir hier auf doktor watson ein
neues video veröffentlichen dann sehen
wir ähnlich wie netflix eine menge daten
zum beispiel können wir recht schnell
erkennen ob ein video gut geklickt wird
oder eher nicht wenn das nicht der fall
ist dann kann das an verschiedenen
dingen liegen
das thema ist nicht interessant der
titel vermittelt nicht wie spannend das
thema wirklich ist vielleicht ist der
zeitpunkt nicht ganz optimal gewesen
oder auch das thumbnail spricht euch
nicht an
worum es im video geht und wann wir das
video veröffentlicht haben das können
wir im nachhinein nicht mehr ändern
was wir aber ändern können sind titel
und samt mail und genau das sind auch
die ersten beiden dinge die ihr seht und
meistens die einzigen die darüber
entscheiden ob wir auf das video klickt
oder nicht deswegen produzieren wir
meistens vor der veröffentlichung eines
videos mehrere mails und überlegen uns
mehrere titel hier zum beispiel für
unser video über messenger dienste
da haben wir allerdings schon nach fünf
minuten gemerkt dass das video relativ
gut ankommt deswegen haben wir das amt
mail und den titel beibehalten
bei diesem video von uns und hat das
erste final allerdings nicht so gut
funktioniert deswegen sind wir auf eine
alternative umgestiegen und
spielerwechsel hat uns dann auch
wirklich mehr zuschauer eingebracht
übrigens frage ich euch auf instagram
und twitter regelmäßig welches am nails
ihr besser findet wenn ihr also da folgt
ex doktor watson dann könnt ihr immer
mit entscheiden wie die videos hier auf
dem kanal aussehen
zumindest wenn sie das erste mal in der
box erscheinen denn je nachdem wie gut
sich ein video am anfang liegt gibt uns
youtube ein ranking
dort sehen wir wie das neue video im
vergleich zu den letzten neuen videos
meines kanals geformt je weiter oben ein
video platziert wird desto besser läuft
es und wenn ein video niedrig einsteigt
kann es gut sein dass wir den titel
display oder sogar beides austauschen
und hoffen dass die neue kombination
besser funktioniert komplett
wissenschaftlich ist das in der praxis
natürlich nicht um richtiges a b testing
zu machen und handfeste
wissenschaftliche daten zu erheben
müssten die bedingungen bei beiden some
nails a und b genau gleich sein
das heißt sie sind zur gleichen zeit
online und user bekommen die fans gleich
viel vorgeschlagen zumindest die auf
youtube ist so eine saubere
laborumgebung aber nicht so leicht zu
gestalten
da haben es die entwickler von netflix
deutlich einfacher bei uns hier auf
youtube entscheidet der youtube
algorithmus ob ihr einen doktor watson
video auf ihrer startseite vorgeschlagen
bekommt oder nicht
und das ist oft eine ziemliche blackbox
wir haben keine kontrolle und auch kein
feedback dazu wann das passiert und wie
oft das
und immer wieder bekommen wir von euch
sogar mit dass manche videos nicht
einmal in der abo box auftauchen obwohl
ihr den kanal abonniert habt wenn
übrigens das verhindern wollt dann könnt
ihr auf unserem kanal die glocke
aktivieren dann bekommt ihr immer eine
benachrichtigung wenn wir etwas neues
hochladen
okay obwohl die daten die wir bekommen
also nicht 100 prozentig neutral sind
sind sie trotzdem hilfreich
wir sehen zum beispiel ob mit einem
neuen thumbnail die klicks steigen oder
sinken auf dauer lernen wir so was
optisch funktioniert und welche titel
euch gefallen
okay das ist natürlich nur das best case
szenario oft lässt sich das nämlich gar
nicht so leicht beantworten
wir haben mittlerweile eine ganz gute
idee und was ankommt experimentieren
aber trotzdem bei fast jedem video aufs
neue mit titeln und terminal herum
aus unserer erfahrung heraus und
funktioniert ein titel mit paradoxon
sehr gut also zum beispiel warum du auf
keinen fall im lotto gewinnen sollte ist
oder warum es keine giraffen gibt man
denkt sich her
natürlich gibt es giraffen wie so
behauptet er dass es keine gibt klick
und ob das dann schon klick date ist
oder nicht dass muss jeder für sich
selber entscheiden
ich bin davon überzeugt dass wir bei
unseren videos etwas lernen könnt und
deswegen ok damit wenn wir hier und da
tricks einsetzen um euch zum klicken zu
bewegen und was übrigens auch sehen
können wenn ihr einmal auf die videos
klickt dann guckt ihr sie zu großen
teilen auch bis zum ende
das ist auf youtube bei weitem nicht
immer der fall was die vom nails angeht
haben wir gemerkt dass ein kino look
also der fokus auf einige wenige
elemente besonders gut funktioniert
genau wie gesichter vielleicht weil es
einen persönlichen eindruck macht dass
uns das gerne mal in den kommentaren
wissen welches amt mails findet ihr am
besten
wobei mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit ist
das was ihr glaubt sehen zu wollen und
was ihr im endeffekt wirklich anklickt
komplett unterschiedlich netflix hat zum
beispiel in einer umfrage herausgefunden
dass sich kunden wünschen schon vor dem
abschluss den gesamten serien und filmen
katalog sehen zu können
klar man will ja auch wissen was der
dienst einem zu bieten hat also haben
sie ausprobiert ob sie so mehr kunden
gewinnen können durch gezielte a b tests
haben die entwickler dann aber gemerkt
dass diese funktion genau das gegenteil
bewirkt nämlich weniger abgeschlossene
abonnements als vorher
netflix hat für diese optimierung sogar
einen eigenen begriff consumer science
also nutzer wissenschaft und auch wenn
bei netflix wahrscheinlich keine
professoren das interface design ist
wissenschaft überhaupt nicht falsch denn
a b testing ist klassische
wissenschaftliche praxis die mitarbeiter
von netflix entwickeln eine hypothese
darauf folgt dann ein experiment um die
hypothese entweder zu bestätigen oder zu
widerlegen und egal ob die hypothese nun
richtig oder falsch war kann man aus dem
test etwas lernen
[Musik]
zwei versionen gegeneinander zu testen
ist übrigens überhaupt nichts neues in
der filmproduktion ist es zb gängige
praxis frühe versionen eines films vor
verschiedenen testgruppen zu zeigen so
fitnessstudios heraus welches ende zum
beispiel besser ankommt viele filme die
du gesehen hast dann also vielleicht mal
ganz anders aus regisseure und
produzenten haben immer eine bestimmte
idee davon wie ihr film oder ihre serie
sein soll durch testgruppen müssten sie
dann aber manchmal von dieser version
abweichen
bei solchen tests setzen studios nämlich
oft bewusst auf menschen die mit der
industrie und dem franchise nichts zu
tun haben
man sucht nach einer generellen meinung
denn am ende des tages geht es darum
eine breite masse zu bedienen und nicht
nur die fanbase
deswegen gibt es zum beispiel auch
manchmal director's cut versionen die
der fanbase dann wesentlich besser
gefallen so hat sich der regisseur das
eigene spiel nicht vorgestellt
unternehmen können aber nicht nur
herausfinden was die allgemeinheit gerne
sieht durch a b tests canet flix zum
beispiel selbst die kleinste zielgruppe
an steuern und das zahlt sich aus denn
marktforschung funktioniert da wir jeden
tag eine ganze reihe an persönlichen
daten teilen wird es immer einfacher
selbst die kleinsten nischen zielgruppe
zu testen und anzusprechen und das sorgt
für eine immer individuellere erfahrung
führt man diesen gedanken mal weiter
dann könnte sich in zukunft deine und
meine online erfahrung immer weiter
voneinander unterscheiden was online
shopping angeht sind wir mittlerweile so
weit dass dein endgerät und bei einer
online aktivität den preis mitbestimmen
und dass du vielleicht ein ganz anderes
sortiment sie ist als ich und wie schon
erwähnt gibt es für serien oder filme ja
mehrere editionen und vor allem auch
mehrere enden was wenn ich in zukunft
auf netflix ein anderes ende sehe als du
weil sich einfach herausgestellt hat
dass ein düsteres ende meiner zielgruppe
besser gefällt
du bist aber in einer anderen
demographie und bekommst das happy end
so könnte man auf jeden fall mehr leute
zufrieden stellen vielleicht ist genau
das die zukunft eine super individuell
zugeschnittene erfahrung genau auf
meinen geschmack aber ob das wirklich
besser ist leitet da nicht die kunstform
des films darunter ein paar der besten
filme aller zeiten waren an der
kinokasse totale flops und sind erst
später bekanntgeworden
wenn man diese filme sofort ab geändert
hätte um zuschauer glücklich zu machen
dann wären diese meisterwerke vielleicht
gar nicht bekanntgeworden
außerdem kann man eventuell nicht mehr
gemeinsam über filme und serien sprechen
da jeder im gespräch ein anderes ende
gesehen hat da geht dann auch total viel
verloren und individualisierung hat
einen teuren preis je personalisierter
die erfahrung sein soll desto genauer
muss das bild sein dass die daten von
mir zeichnen
ob dieser preis es wert ist das muss
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
und das würde mich jetzt mal von euch
interessieren schreibt mir gerne mal in
die kommentare nach unten ob ihr so ein
individualisiertes netflix gerne sehen
wollt und ob wir bereit wert noch mehr
eurer daten dafür herzugeben und ist
auch schon aufgefallen dass euer netflix
anders aussieht als das von einem
bekannten also mich nur die anordnung
der filme sondern auch dass dieselben
filme
andere bilder haben wie sagt schaffen
wir gerne mal unten in die kommentare
ansonsten mal vielen dank fürs zuschauen
bleibt neugierig war cedric